the san francisco 49ers have been doing
enough to win games albeit against not
great teams with pretty much everyone on
the team injured good news george kittle
back after missing two games with a knee
injury and debo samuel who was great
last year in his rookie season as a
receiver and also running the ball as a
receiver he makes his season debut this
weekend sunday night football shireen
eagles coming to town 49ers get another
favorable spot on the schedule as they
try to get some guys healthy before they
get some tough games and there is a spot
coming up
where the 49ers are going to be tested
week in and week out for like five
straight weeks get your wins while you
can get healthy while you can because
the storm is coming
and it's still impressive mike with what
they've been able to do with as many
starters as they've had out they've had
10 starters out last week i know it was
a giants i get it but still to to do
what they did and beat that team it is
an nfl team without 10 projected
starters is pretty incredible to me it
just shows you how deep they are at so
many different positions that they can
just continually lose guys and bounce
back there aren't many teams in the nfl
they could lose their starting
quarterback and and play like they did
last week but i don't know if you
remember this or not and i do only
because i think it's being proved right
right now
is we we had a discussion about the
teams with the best group of
quarterbacks and i picked the 49ers and
this is the reason i picked the 49ers
because i thought a lot of nick mullins
after the way he played in 2018
and then you look at the third
quarterback cj beathard may be the best
third quarterback in football and i just
don't think they lose a lot when they
put nick mullins in there for jimmy
garoppolo i think a lot of jimmy
garoppolo but nick mullins is a really
good talented backup quarterback and you
know in 2018 when he played those eight
games he targeted george kittle 29 of
the time and he loves george kittle so i
think you're going to see a lot of
kittle this week from nick mullins
well here's kittle talking about nick
mullins who'll be in it yet again for
jimmy garoppolo
you know you guys know i love i love
nick um
he's the same every single day and
that's why i love him and even when he's
at practice it feels like it's a game
with him and that's what i love about
him he just always he's always locked in
and he's always just ready to roll and
he is a leader out there you know he
um
he leads in a different way he just you
know leads with his play which is what i
respect he never messes up he's just
there he's consistent he just works hard
and i think that's that's just what our
team responds well to is just guys that
go out there they do their job they do
it at a high level and that's what nick
does every single day um you know i love
watching nick play i mean we have a
connection i mean i love all three of
our quarterbacks i think they're all
great qbs and
getting the chance to play with nick
again i'm excited about it
you know because it's bdn and he's a
great qb
look it's a system driven offense and
nick mullins has been in the system for
several years now he knows it well he
knows how to do what kyle shanahan wants
to do and the whole idea is if you have
a quarterback who can and will do what
kyle shanahan expects on any given play
the offense will work there isn't a lot
of discretion there isn't a lot of
freelancing it's a b c d do what you're
expected to do and if you make the
decisions that you're told to make ahead
of time when you see certain things when
you focus on your keys it will work and
you will end up being a good quarterback
and nick mullins doing it so far for the
san francisco 49ers but serene i
mentioned this schedule and
they're starting a three-game home stand
they get the eagles and then the
dolphins and then the fun begins
although it may prompt another word that
begins with f for the 49ers the rams at
the patriots at the seahawks the packers
at the saints by week at the rams
the bills what in the world
are they looking at from week six
through week 13 so
fatten up while you can because
it could be we remember last year when
they had that horrific stretch of like
three games and we were like man what
are they going to do it's like seven
games this year
that's a tough schedule when you start
breaking it down you're right they
better win the
the first five and they got some on the
back end that looked winnable although
you know you look at the cardinals have
already beaten them and the cowboys
could beat them and
you know washington's not going to be
easy and see the rest of that schedule
after that dolphins game starting with
week six is just a gauntlet and it's
going to be very tough and i like the
49ers i think they have a really good
team i think it's going to be very very
difficult for them to
repeat in that division i do think they
get to the playoffs but that's just
tough and it's going to be week after
week after weekend within as many
injuries as they had if they're not
healthy it's going to make it even that
much harder
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports